for everyone out there looking to get
hashtag vaxxed and relaxed this summer
grub street reports it's officially
cosmo
season hey this is my favorite season
they say carrie bradshaw's favorite
cocktail is the drink of
the summer it's spring but you can
always start early right rossi
cosmo mg do you remember this summer
uh during the lockdown cosmos had a new
life when
barefoot contessa inagarten did her uh
version of the look at the cosmos she
made remember that
i like her i like her for every reason i
love the barefoot in a garden
we would give anything to work with you
yeah
and you know what now that i've seen
your cocktail i'm a little jealous of
hold on oh thank you okay i got this man
i mean that she inspired me that's an
eine cocktail thank you so much
you know what i think we need to call
that what the rosmo
okay okay drew
right how did i think of that and not
you i don't know now i'm thinking one
for drew but
i i need a minute you know what i did
this weekend i told you i was up in
connecticut we were driving around
do you love just like looking at houses
there were a couple open houses and i
went in because i'm obsessed with real
estate right
real estate is my porn well you're not
alone drew
a new survey confirms what we already
knew america is zillow obsessed
house beautiful reports a survey of a
thousand people found
that 49 of people would rather look at
zillow that real estate app
than have sex
that's not all 58 have missed a deadline
at work because they're scrolling
through zillow uh-huh i believe that
yes 56 of people admit they cancelled
plans with friends
just to scroll and browse zillow all
right that one is odd
okay i love this one 63 of people say
they've looked up the value of their
friend's house
which i was shocked that it was that low
because
rude it's so rude oh naughty
have you ever done it no i haven't but i
never thought to do it
um and then there's a there's a last
deet i found interesting too
yeah 64 of people have contacted an
agent for a home that they can't afford
well come on the real estate game is i'm
going to show you something that's above
your price range so you fall in love
with it and like
find a way to make it work i don't like
looking at the houses if i'm really
shopping for something that's out of my
price range because it's just like it's
just
torture it's torture and then you get
your house you're like whatever
we all sometimes need to get out of our
own lives and fantasize about a
different one
totally and there's something about a
house that is like
the anchor to dreaming about being
doing something else it's such an outlet
it is it's aspirational i get design
ideas look at people houses and i get
you know ideas of what not to do i've
seen some of your living rooms
we're like a noop not to judge but
a little bit it's fun i don't know
sometimes for me it's it's an escapism
yeah recently i was just having such a
hard time with kids home school
i was just hitting a wall and i started
looking
on zillow at other places and the
coolest thing happened
what i realized i loved exactly where i
am
oh drew barrymore you took a left turn
and i didn't see that happening
you